E
BEGINNING OF THE LAST TWO DAYS
OF A VERY LONG TRIP THROUGH
EUROPE.
>> Bill: JAMIE WETZEL IS WITH
ME RIGHT NOW.
GOOD MORNING TO YOU.
I'M NOT SURE OF YOUR LOCATION,
BUT THANK YOU FOR JOINING US.
WHAT YOU THINK ABOUT THIS IDEA
TO GO OUT AND PUT OUT SOMETHING
WHERE THESE TWO LEADERS COULD
AGREE?
WHAT YOU THINK?
>> I THINK WE NEED A FULL
INVESTIGATION INTO THE ORIGINS
OF THIS TERRIBLE PANDEMIC.
WE'VE NEEDED IT SINCE DAY ONE.
CHINA HAS BEEN BLOCKING THAT.
IT HAS BEEN VERY DIFFICULT FOR
PEOPLE LIKE ME AND OTHERS TO
RAISE THE CRITICAL ISSUE BUT NOW
IT'S OPENING UP AND THERE IS A
REAL THOUGHT THAT IT COULD HAVE
ESCAPED FROM A LAB IN THIS
PANDEMIC DID HAVE SOME JUMP IN
THE WILD.
THAT'S WHY WE NEED RECORD
SAMPLES WITH PERSONAL.
IT'S AMAZING THAT AFTER YEAR AND
A HALF OF THE INITIAL OUTBREAK
WE STILL DON'T HAVE THAT.
>> Bill: WHAT DO YOU THINK.
>> WHAT DO I THINK?
I THINK IT'S TERRIBLE.
>> Bill: IN TERMS OF THE
ORIGIN.
WHAT DO YOU THINK?
SPEAK UP I HAVE THIS ON MY JAMIE
METAL.COM WEBSITE.
I THINK IT'S MOST LIKELY A LAB
INCIDENT ORIGIN.
IT STARTS AND WUHAN WHERE THEY
DON'T HAVE ANY HORSESHOE BATS IN
THE WILD.
THEY HAVE CHINA'S ONLY LEVEL FOR
VIROLOGY INSTITUTE WITH THE
LARGEST COLLECTION OF BACK
CORONAVIRUS IS.
AS REDFIELD CORRECTLY STATES,
AND SHOWS UP ON DAY ONE READY TO
INFECT HUMANS AND THAT IS VERY
DISSIMILAR FROM ALL OTHER
PATHOGENIC OUTBREAKS AND THE
WILD THAT WE'VE SEEN IN THE
PAST.
THERE'S SOME REALLY BIG
QUESTIONS.
IN MY MIND, THEY POINT TOWARD
BUT NOT DO NOT CONCLUSIVELY
PROVE A LAB INCIDENT ORIGIN
WHICH IS WHY WE NEED A FULL
INVESTIGATION.
>> Bill: I DON'T KNOW IF YOU
CAN SEE THE PROGRAMMING WHERE
YOU ARE JAMIE, BUT THE PRESIDENT
HAS JUST ARRIVED IN GENEVA.
HE HAS A LITTLE GREETING PARTY
THERE ON THE TARMAC AND WE WILL
SEE AFTER THIS.
THE POINT BEING HERE, THERE ARE
STATES IN THE U.S. THAT ARE
READY TO GO 100% OPEN IT ALL
APPEARED FOR HER AUNT WAS THE
FIRST ONE YESTERDAY AND NEW YORK
WAS RIGHT ON THE CUSP OF DOING
THIS.
RUSSIA IS IN A DIFFERENT PLACE.
>> I CERTAINLY HOPE SO.
IT IS IN EVERYBODY'S INTEREST TO
GET TO THE BOTTOM OF THIS.
AS YOU KNOW, RUSSIA AND CHINA
HAVE AN INCREASINGLY COZY
RELATIONSHIP AND BECAUSE CHINA
IS BLOCKING THE KIND OF FULL
INVESTIGATION THAT WE NEED IT,
MY GUESS IS THAT PUTIN IS GOING
TO BE A LITTLE BIT CAUTIOUS
ABOUT PUTTING TOO MUCH PRESSURE
ON HIS FRIEND XI JINPING.
IF THAT IS THE CASE, IT'S
UNFORTUNATE.
BECAUSE EVERYBODY, INCLUDING
EVERYBODY AND CHINA, IS A
BENEFICIARY OF UNDERSTANDING
WHAT WENT WRONG SO WE CAN
IDENTIFY AND FIX OUR BIGGEST
PROBLEMS AND BUILD A SAFER
FUTURE FOR EVERYBODY.
>> Bill: IT SEEMS LIKE AN EASY
THING TO DO ESPECIALLY WITH
PEOPLE IN RUSSIA STILL HURTING
FROM THIS.
>> DOCTOR SHE GENERALLY FROM
CHINA, I KNOW THAT YOU KNOW THE
NAME.
HOW CAN I COME OFF OF SOMETHING
WHERE THERE WAS NO EVIDENCE.
>> I DID SEE.
WHAT SHE IS BASICALLY SAYING IS
THAT WE SHOULD NOT JUST TRUST
HER BUT THE CHINESE AUTHORITIES.
THE SAME CHINESE AUTHORITIES WHO
HAVE BEEN ENGAGED IN THIS
MASSIVE COVER-UP SINCE DAY ONE
INCLUDING DESTROYING SAMPLES,
DESTROYING RECORDS, IMPRISONING
CITIZEN JOURNALISTS,
IMPLEMENTING GAG ORDERS, BARRING
CHINESE SCIENTISTS FROM WRITING
OR PUBLISHING ANYTHING WITHOUT
CHINESE GOVERNMENT APPROVAL.
SHOULD WE TRUST THE CHINESE
GOVERNMENT?
THE SAME GOVERNMENT THAT IS
ENGAGED IN A GENOCIDE.
THE CHINESE GOVERNMENT HAS
DENIGRATED THE TRUST THAT MANY
PEOPLE HOPE THEY CAN PLACE ON
THEM.
>> Bil